un paso más cerca de la extradición para
julian assange después de que la
secretaria del interior británica diera
su aprobación la decisión de principal
se produce después de que el tribunal
superior británico dictaminará en abril
que el fundador de wikileaks podría ser
enviado a eeuu tras considerar que el
procedimiento no sería incompatible con
sus derechos humanos la abogada de
assange dice que la decisión del viernes
debe ser vista como una llamada de
atención de soria
esto debería conmocionar y preocupar a
todo el mundo a cada ciudadano a cada
periodista a cada editor a cada
organización de medios de comunicación
seguiremos apelando este no es el final
del camino under the rivers por su parte
la esposa del denunciante se ha
comprometido a luchar por la libertad de
su marido en todo momento advirtiendo
que podría quitarse la vida si es
extraditado
no tengo palabras para expresar lo que
significa y yo sí que el proceso del
reino unido se utilice como una forma de
prolongar el sufrimiento de julian una y
otra vez
a sánchez buscado por las autoridades
estadounidenses por 16 cargos distintos
entre ellos el de espionaje relacionado
con la publicación de registros
militares y cables diplomáticos
confidenciales hace más de una década
según el ministerio del interior tiene
14 días para apelar esta última decisión
en caso de que los tribunales concedan
una audiencia podrían pasar meses antes
de que se fije una fecha hasta antes
también podría presentar un recurso ante
el tribunal europeo de derechos humanos
mientras continúan las maniobras legales
el australiano permanece en una prisión
británica de alta seguridad tras ser
considerado un riesgo de fuga en su caso
de extradición se enfrenta hasta 175
años de prisión si es condenado en eeuu